well joining me now in the studio to
talk more about this is dr. Falk or
Buddha he heads the department of
radiation oncology at the sheraton
Hospital here in Berlin thank you for
being with us today dr. Bruna now heavy
ion therapy worked for the patient in
that last report but how optimistic are
you about this treatment for tumors
protons and heavy ions have physical
properties which put them into a
favorite role for the treatment of
cancer patients in the future especially
because they can be stopped right after
a tumor and within several mini meters
can be come down from 100% or 0% so the
burden of radiation to normal tissue can
be considerably spared okay what about
side effects side effect should be about
in the range as with conventional
radiation except for secondary tumors
where we expect more secondary tumors
and conventional radiation therapy than
for this kind of irradiation all right
what kinds of cancers are best treated
with ion beams mainly these should be
children tumors and children because of
the secondary neoplasms as I already
mentioned and then of course tumors
which are in the direct vicinity of very
radio sensitive structures like for
instance the optic nerves or small bowel
or spinal cord all right and what has
been your personal experience with
particle beam therapies particle beam
Terrace therapies have been done in my
career when I was still in essen
University and we had there in Neutron
facility for Neutron irradiation which
is a heavy particle and which was of
course not so focused like today all
right now this treatment is not for
everyone is not available everywhere in
the world it's very costly that machine
costs up to 200 million euros so would
you then say it's a realistic method for
cancer patients yes it might be in the
future when we have or we will have
compact machine
which are much smaller they have not
treatment rooms like in these huge
machine facilities of four or five but
only one and this can be build up in
every large clinic or a university unit
and then treat about 4 or 500 patients a
year now how does the ion beam therapy
compare with other forms of radiation it
should principally it should have some
advantages but there are no proofs until
now that it really works better than
photons or the normal conventional
radiotherapy therefore we are doing for
in the future lots of clinical trials to
at the end yeah rule out what is better
best or not okay and speaking of the
future what is the future of cancer
treatments then I think it's a local
treatment optimization of a local
treatment and local tumors and as soon
as they are disseminated you need of
course systemic treatments okay dr.
Bhutta it has been very interesting
having this discussion with you today
thank you for being with us